um so how do you get from being a kid
from Stockton who's been through so much
[__] uh to LA
well I had a job I mean before
entertainment I worked for a labor union
called SEIU I was the staff director for
Kaiser Permanente so Kaiser hospitals
all throughout California I was one of
the three directors who who led a team
of organizers who organized all the
Hospitals and Clinics so um that came by
way of me losing my job but being you
know very vocal with the city about what
I felt was right or wrong about the
firing they saw me advocating for myself
they offered me a job I was a Kaiser
patient at the time I felt like yo now
I'm going to be a Kaiser patient with
the privilege of advocating for other
patients at the level of organizing the
leaders so I did that work for 11 years
and when we merged with at the time it
was local 250 emerged with local 399 it
became
sciuhw I was the first to have to come
down and help lead the Statewide program
to really move people into what the
union was going to be about and uh when
I got here I had established so many
relationships from visiting over the
years
have you met Queen Latif for 30 years
ago and just over there's many people so
when I got here and I started going to
Supper Club I started going to Ladue I
started going to Garden of Eden then I
started popping up at Jamie Foxx I just
fell in love with the industry again
from a idea that I could abandon my job
to follow my dreams and over time it
happened and naturally when it was time
I just went Hollywood online full time
when did uh when did you like make the
decision to quit the job was it like
because you made a certain amount of
money oh they fired me oh they fired you
so you had really kind of like no choice
they didn't fire me because I did
anything wrong when we merged with the
the unions there became a lot of inner
Union fighting that I was it just was
beyond my pay grade so when they removed
our president I was very loyal to the
leadership and very I'm a loyal person
like when I arrived for you or ride with
you I'm 10 toes down period I don't care
what nobody says unless you do some real
crazy [__] right so they removed the
president and and they took all the
staff there was probably 300 some staff
they took us all into different hotels
around the state and we were faced with
a a decision you either
sign a letter and say that you to all
the members you've LED for all these
years that you were lying to them all
this time
or you just quit so we're faced with a
decision of lying to the people or
quitting and I just decided to quit and
I just quit so from there it was like
I'm all in now there's no other choice
there's no choice that's why it's our
conglomerate group and I started putting
oh you want Chris Brown oh you want this
person okay 10 10 I started 10 in my my
way into survival mode middle man in a
lot of deals absolutely I still do it's
a great hustle I still do it to this day
yeah that's dope yeah I mean that's good
to know so so for you like when did you
do you remember like a month or like a a
point in time where you really realized
like there was really like some tread
hitting the ground with Hollywood
unlocked like you could you could turn
this into something that was like I mean
I can't remember the moment where I go
this is actually doing something like I
remember when we first started we
started with a hundred dollars what year
was this it's 2015. October 100
Instagram website and then while I was
building it I called Mona to get on Love
and Hip Hop but while I was doing it we
were so head down in the work that we
weren't paying attention to the growth
we just we weren't counting numbers
counting followers counting comments we
were just so into the work and
perfecting the storytelling and what was
going to differentiate us from our
competitors and how are we working with
those competitors to be collaborators
and we just head down and then I
remember we went from like zero
followers to like I remember I remember
the day we went to six we had 60 000
because that was the day where we were
like damn we got 60 000 followers that's
a lot that's a lot yeah and then and
then I remember one day he had a hundred
and it was 300 then it was 500 then it
was a million and so I remember all
those moments of where we were hitting
those milestones and we just kept trying
to perfect the the um consumer
experience because ultimately we at
first were just a place we're talking
about what was hard what was going on
but then people started picking us up
and we were going all across the world
in different news trades and then we
started seeing politicians reach out so
we're like oh damn then I remember an
article came out that we swayed an
election so I'm like okay we have real
influence which election was it this was
back home in Stockton okay I literally
just said my opinion on something and it
got picked up by L.A times and then
different people ran and then the the
vote literally it swayed and the person
came out and said that it disgruntled
work a disgruntled former resident who
used his platform for him to lose and it
wasn't true it was just that you weren't
a good mayor and you needed to go so
once I started seeing our influence
then I was like yeah we're really honing
in on making sure that we were hitting
all uh demographics so pop culture all
things culture politics how do we hit
all these three things from a world
perspective like what do people want to
hear that the whole world can talk about
what can they talk about in Nigeria that
they'll talk about in London that
they'll talk about in La that they're
going to talk about in Arkansas how do
we create that content and then it
became a very strategic thing where then
we started looking at the needle like
okay this got 12 million views or this
guy okay now this show got x amount of
that's how we really looked at the
growth and now we're just we're just
growing